good morning everyone my name is
researcher Miller and the SCP were going
to be studying today is scp-1678 object
class Euclid special containment
procedures scp-1678 remains only
partially contained mobile task forces
tau for and epsilon six have succeeded
in establishing a defense perimeter
around the Hyde Park District of
scp-1678 with cases of scp-1678 a
largely ceasing their attacks on the
perimeter of the foundation held area a
long term research base is currently
under construction and mobile task force
commanders are preparing an assault on
the scp-1678 Natural History Museum with
the intent of capturing a forward
command post to direct defense efforts
current short term aims involve the
capture of an extension of the
defensible perimeter to scp-1678 Natural
History Museum and to research and
ascertain the origins construction and
weaknesses of the scp-1678 a entities
long-term aims involve efforts to halt
hinder or control the reduction of
scp-1678 a entities and to assault the
scp-1678 houses of parliament where the
being entity or intelligence responsible
for the creation of scp-1678 is believed
to reside and to capture and contain the
ever mention being
[Music]
description scp-1678 is a full-scale
mirror image reconstruction of the
british city of london located exactly
one kilometer underneath the original
city of london currently only the Hyde
Park District of scp-1678 has been
explored but all buildings at least
within the explored district correlate
exactly to their surface counterparts in
terms of location as well as the
exterior size and shape although rarely
in terms of architecture building
material and interior layout the city
has been constructed to resemble the
city as it was in the Victorian era with
constructions designed to resemble
traditional gas lighting prevalent on
the streets and with all modern
buildings in the original City of London
being represented in a Victorian style
of architecture most notably the
skyscrapers of the business district
illumination is infrequent and
unreliable and it is unknown how
scp-1678 has acquired a steady oxygen
and gas supply scp-1678 is believed to
have been constructed instantaneously by
unknown means with the scp-1678 houses
of parliament serving as the epicenter
for the construction process this is
evidenced by the fact that as distance
from the houses of Parliament's increase
there is an exponentially increasing
frequency of flaws in the construction
of scp-1678 such as houses built
entirely out of copper pipes or other
unconventional materials gas lights
being little more than a metal rod
topped with a floating orb of life
buildings containing no floors and at
the furthest explored distance from the
epicentre no windows or doors aside from
the foundation occupants and cases of
scp-1678 a B and C scp-1678 is believed
to be uninhabited scp-1678 is believed
to have been constructed with the intent
to harbor the survivors of annex cake
end-of-the-world event this is evidenced
by an audio recording that will activate
and play upon any person and during the
city
the following is scp-1678 audio
recording entrance - on London my fellow
citizen if you are here in this tape
then the world as we knew it has
finished the sky has broken the ground
heaves with a [ __ ] of terrible deed and
all madness from the dark corners of the
world has broken free to exact his
vengeance on the world of man those who
sought to contain them are killed or
scattered and we soon learned not to
attempt to fight these creatures is
almost invariably
two-face ones death countless billions
have been slaughtered in their attempt
to sate their endless appetite for death
and there is nothing was nothing we
could do to stop them evil has raised
its bloody flag upon all nations of the
world and crowd it's unholy victory to
the broken sky yes this is the end but
there is a new hope welcome to our
London a city of survivors a city of the
free together fellow citizen we will
wait and prepare for the new beginning
the grand new world that is soon to come
the world
then we will endure let the monsters
have their world we will prepare and let
the ground tremble with a new Armageddon
as evil consumes itself before I tell
you citizen upon the day of the
ruination of man their insatiable
appetites will turn them against one
another in their endless lust or their
we will wait and I tell you citizen that
there will be a new morning and you will
emerge from um London and stand blinking
in the Sun as our children play and
laugh in the bones of Horrors long dead
and you will work hand in hand to the
sea our faces sky ones as the Rising Sun
rushes in the new age of man and you
will gather citizen at my feet as I
summon on London from its rest and it
shall burst phoenix-like
from the ashes of the old and on that
day citizen there shall be a new order
as we raise the Union flag over the
entire world I welcome you to one London
the last City and the first
there are other audio recordings here I
will describe each one before I plate
the following message is relayed on the
end of every hour obviously every hour
wouldn't say 9 o'clock for any of you
smart asses out there that was just an
example this plays on approaching a bank
or police station citizen you are
entering a restricted area
have your authorization papers ready we
will arrive to ask you shortly
warning a single case of a CP 1678 a
will be summoned on being cited by a
case of scp-1678 a the following audio
lines play helped police drop your
weapons now let's be having you
police don't grab randomly once per hour
the messages below are selected examples
of the 1678 observed audio recordings no
one is safe from the influence of
memetic beings have your self assess
today you could be possessed by a
mimetic holler and not even know it
psych assessments are free and easy
visit a clinic today do you find light
uncomfortable identifying a cortex worms
in section early makes impossible to
remove speak to your doctor today
have you noticed anyone acting oddly
tell our body immediately Prime will not
be tolerated in on London I warn you
the tormentors of society will become
its defenders evil convert inhuman firm
and human flesh stay vigilant
I will frequently anxious or depressed
it could be a symptom of the pattern
screamer's influence notifiable bay
immediately ensure you are well
rehearsed in all breach protocols there
is no excuse for panic or confusion
during drills and make ends meet do not
be ashamed
Bryson's home for the poor is here to
help I rule in interests of the many not
the few there are no special privileges
swelling that bubble growths are an
early sign of the slave a man's
possession report any abnormal sickness
to your doctor immediately each and
every one of you is responsible for the
safety of London and its citizens be
watchful most explored buildings within
scp-1678 appear to have been outfitted
for the purpose of extremely dense and
habitation with closely grouped steel
bunk beds a common feature in any
building suitable for the purpose
foundation researchers have advised that
most explored buildings within scp-1678
are unfit for human habitation due to a
high performance of mould damp and poor
construction within these buildings some
buildings are outfitted for other
purposes most notably the scp-1678
version of the Natural History Museum
which is featuring an exhibit titled the
fall of man and contains representations
of several known SCP entities and images
and artwork depicting apocalyptic
settings the key threat posed by
scp-1678
is by entities referred to in some
scp-1678 audio recordings as Bobby's
Bobby is known to be a Victorian II or a
British slang term for policeman
henceforth referred to as scp-1678 a
these entities are constructed out of
human corpses crudely dismembered at the
head wrists knees and elbows and
reassembled using industrial hinges and
screws the head is always wrapped in
bandages they are dressed in a uniform
similar to Victorian era police and our
extremely hostile towards foundation
personnel attacking them on-site with
improvised weapons these attacks are
always preceded by scp-1678 a amending a
noise similar to that of a policeman's
whistle and all loudspeakers within 100
metres omitting the audio recording
police halt criminal instances of
scp-1678 a are extremely resistant to
damage with only high-caliber rounds and
explosive weapons proving sufficient to
destroy them they are believed to
originate from a building named Bryson's
home for the poor as evidenced by an
inmate style jumpsuit worn under the
uniform to what extent they interact
with other scp-1678 entities is unknown
the following is scp-1678 b overview
scp-1678 b-roll surveillance also known
as eyes in the sky cases of scp-1678 B
are biomechanical constructs which
resemble that of a small avian life-form
they are composed of central mass of a
red organic matter stitched together by
a copper exoskeleton that resembles the
spine and wing bones the head has been
demonstrated to be a small video camera
and remnants of feathers and plastic on
the exterior suggests they were once
intended to resemble a pigeon cases of
scp-1678 B are known to possess no
offensive or destructive cape
ladies yet their ability to track task
force movements should not be
underestimated as it is currently known
if they are capable of communicating
with or summoning cases of scp-1678 a
cases of scp-1678 B are relatively
simple to contain or destroy yet they're
large numbers makes their observational
foundation activities extremely
difficult to stop occasional posters
throughout the foundation explored area
allude to their existence these posters
display an image of a small pigeon
observing criminal activity beneath the
title on London's eyes in the sky
alongside a small message to the effect
that anyone destroying or vandalizing an
eye in the sky faces up to 6 weeks at
the unit and this is the scp-1678 see
overview scp-1678 c roll unknown also
known as wrench cases of scp-1678 c
resemble a humanoid figure dressed in
rags they appeared to be of old age and
are usually although not always female
they have always been encountered
outside the foundation held area there
have been very few direct encounters
with scp-1678 C entities and it is
currently unknown how many cases exist
or to what level of threat they pose to
foundation security or safety encounters
typically feature cases of scp-1678 c
sitting on a street corner with a
begging dish whereupon they will attempt
to attract the pity or mercy of any
foundation personnel within their
proximity with pleading or begging for
food or money
supplying a case of scp-1678 see with
food will cause them to begin weeping
before dematerializing with a burst of
dense black smoke foundation personnel
are currently under instruction to not
interact with them they are briefly
alluded to in a CP 1678 audio recording
do not pity the wrench allow them to pay
the price of their betrayal for all
eternity
remember citizen on the day on London
rises I shall reward the loyal but
traitors shall be forever damned and
finally this is scp-1678-d overview
scp-1678-d roll food supply also known
as doctor goodies wonder food scp-1678-d
is believed to be the primary food
source on offer in the event that
scp-1678 receives full scale occupation
scp-1678-d is freely and easily
available from steel vending machines
installed in virtually every building or
structure outfitted for the purpose of
habitation the vending machines are
upright steel pumps similar in size and
shape to that of a modern petrol pump
containing a slot for the receiving of
coins and a flexible rubber hose ending
in a trigger operated nozzle that will
deploy half a liter of 1678 D upon
appropriate payment all vending machines
display the legend doctor goodies wonder
food alongside an image of a smiling
child enjoying a bowl of scp-1678-d and
text bubbles advising that sixteenths of
an ad costs just a farthing a bowl that
it contains all the nutrients you need
and completely restores health and
vitality it is proven to be extremely
attractive two cases of scp-1678 B C an
unknown species of colored mollusk which
has been observed feeding on any
spillages scp-1678-d is a synthetic
starch gel heavily enriched with various
minerals vitamins fats and bulking
agents
in addition to this it contains several
unknown molecular structures and various
engineered DNA helixes carried within
synthetic cellular structures it has the
same consistency and taste as porridge
as advertised it contains all the
nutrients necessary for short-term
survival however foundation researches
have advised that over a period of more
than six weeks users of scp-1678-d will
become dangerously underweight due to
low levels of fat and protein within
scp-1678-d and are at a strong
likelihood of contracting illnesses such
as scurvy if survival is attempted by
consuming scp-1678-d alone scp-1678-d
appears to be purposely engineered to
manipulate the psyche of the regular
consumers through a mixture of unknown
molecular compounds regular consumers
are more obedient to Authority are less
likely to commit acts of violence and
are less likely to engage in sexual
intercourse have a reduced capacity for
fear or panic and have consistently high
morale in addition it also has
engineered side effects such as
depressive symptoms and headaches if a
subject suddenly abandons consuming
scp-1678-d due to the difficulty of
creating food within scp-1678 scp-1678-d
would serve as the primary food source
in the event of a large-scale habitation
Foundation personnel are forbidden to
consume scp-1678-d even in small amounts
not all vending machines produce
scp-1678-d to the same quality with some
machines deploying corrupted forms that
have induced severe mental or physical
abnormalities or death within the
consumer it is currently unclear what
entity being or intelligence is
responsible for the creation and
maintenance of scp-1678 it is unclear as
to what event or disaster scp-1678 is
being
prepared for all right chances are if
you are assigned to this SCP you'll be
trying to find that out this concludes
my lecture for today thank you very much
for listening goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre that shipped
thank you very much Andre your pledge is
very much appreciated if you would like
to know how you can get a personalized
thank e at the end of each of my videos
as well as some other really cool stuff
as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
[Music]
you